tengo las gráficas de tres funciones por
aquí y nos dicen que una de ellas
representa la función f otra su primera
derivada y la última su segunda derivada
y no sabemos cuál es cuál así que como
siempre pausa este vídeo e intenta
encontrar la relación
bueno la forma en la que voy a intentar
resolverlo es ver las gráficas y pensar
en cómo se tendría que ver la derivada
en esta primera gráfica la pendiente de
la recta tangente es un poquito negativa
y después se hace más y más y más y más
negativa y cuando nos aproximamos a
estas en total vertical parece que nos
estamos aproximando a menos infinito así
que la derivada por aquí es un poco
menos que cero después es cada vez más
más y más negativa y después tiende a
menos infinito así que tiene la misma
forma al menos igual a la parte
izquierda de la gráfica que tenemos
hasta antes de la sin tota y ahora qué
pasa a la derecha del asiento está bueno
a la derecha de la 5ta parece que
empezamos con una pendiente muy negativa
observan pero después pasa a ser menos
negativa y después menos negativa y
menos y menos y menos negativa y parece
que se aproxima a cero así que la
derivada de este lado debe de empezar
y después la derivada debe de ser
asiento trasero algo así por lo tanto
con base en lo que acabamos de decir
parece que un buen candidato para la
derivada de la función representada en
la primera gráfica es esta tercera
gráfica y bueno tal vez lo primero que
piensas es qué tiene de malo la segunda
gráfica para descartarla como la
derivada de la primera y la razón es que
la gráfica de azul justo al principio es
positiva
así que si ésta fuera la derivada de la
primera gráfica significaría que la
gráfica de la izquierda debería de tener
una pendiente positiva en esta parte lo
cual no es cierto tenemos una pendiente
ligeramente negativa que pasa a ser una
pendiente muy negativa como lo tenemos
representado en la tercera gráfica y
después una pendiente muy negativa que
después se vuelve a cinto está 0 así que
puedo decir que tal vez esta sea nuestra
función
efe y por lo tanto está de acá sería
nuestra función f prima y ahora pensemos
qué pasa con esta gráfica del medio que
hace su derivada por aquí mi pendiente
es ligera
negativa y después empezamos a tener una
pendiente un poco más negativa y más y
más y más negativa así que la derivada
de esta función se tendría que ver
primero como una pendiente ligeramente
negativa y después más y más y más
negativa mientras nos aproximamos a esta
cinta vertical y ahora en el lado
derecho de esta cinta vertical observa
tenemos una pendiente muy positiva por
aquí y después tenemos una pendiente
menos y menos y menos positiva así que
la derivada se tendrá que ver primero
muy positiva y después tendría que tomar
un valor a menos y menos y menos
positivo de hecho parece que la
pendiente de mi recta tangente es asunto
está cero entonces mi gráfica se vería
más o menos así por lo tanto mi gráfica
de la izquierda me parece un muy buen
candidato para la derivada de mi gráfica
de azul así que ya está diré que ésta es
nuestra efe y esta gráfica del principio
va a ser la derivada de f entonces serán
f prima y como ya establecimos
tercera gráfica es la derivada de la
primera entonces la derivada de la
primera nuestra prima es fbi prima y me
siento bastante bien con este resultado
sólo para tener más claro esto podemos
ver cómo se ve la gráfica de esta
función derivada de mi tercera gráfica
ok primero tenemos la pendiente que es
negativa y después es más y más y más
negativa así que la derivada tendrá la
misma forma por aquí y después por aquí
mi pendiente sería positiva y después
sería menos y menos y menos positiva así
que empezó muy positiva y después se
hace cada vez menos positiva ahora la
forma se parece mucho a esta primera
gráfica pero la razón del por qué no voy
a elegir a la primera gráfica como la
derivada de la tercera es porque esta
tercera gráfica es la única que es una
buena candidata para hacer la derivada
de la primera así que me siento bastante
convencido de que hicimos la elección
correcta la gráfica de azul es efe la de
anaranjado es f prima y la de magenta es
fbi prima
nos vemos en el siguiente